we recently asked the question what
really makes
a relationship last decade after decade
and for the answer
we met an incredible couple named
richard and rhoda and they've been
married for 52
years and they have three kids and four
grandchildren
here's what they had to say in this
never before seen edition
of drew's love bug take a look
our core values are to say you know
religion
education trustworthy
uh respect one another just a
good-hearted
people you know we get along most of the
time
nothing is really that into the world i
say
either help it if it's something that
she want to do and it don't hurt me
and it helps her then why not do it
you know if she wants to go to the
casino i would never go to a casino
but if
and she's happy you know what's the big
deal it's two hours
out of my life and it makes her hair
you know that whole look we're opposites
and that being a bad thing
i'm like why is everybody obsessed with
you melding into one person you're two
people
you should have different interests yes
you're right about the core values
connecting and i think it's really great
advice for people
in fact we have a couple of our vffs our
virtual
friends and family or virtual friends
forever
depending on who you're talking to um
would you be kind enough to
impart some of your wisdom with them
i'm not yes sure okay
excellent okay well first we have
newlywed couple jessica and freddie who
have been married for only a little over
a month oh
hi guys 20 20 brought you guys something
wonderful that's
excellent yes it did hi drew we've
actually been married for 52
days 52 years 52 days how cool is that
i love the symmetry of that that feels
just really really aligned and
sort of perfect um do you guys have a
question
for um richard and rhoda
when you and your partners disagree what
do you do to resolve it so it doesn't
become a bigger issue
later on i know i'm not perfect
and forgiveness is a part of my core
being because
if you want to be forgiven you have to
forgive people
or a person but i love him enough to
know
that it doesn't matter he always said
well you'll get to the point where
we we disagree to disagree
so he has his opinion and you're not
going to change that person's mind
by trying to force them to understand
your way
of thinking because that's you're
entitled to that
see i want to go to the health and and
the harm part if
if it's not a real big issue and it
really it and if the wife really wants
it
and it don't hurt you and it helps her
then what's the big deal and vice versa
tell them about the number game the two
it's like two and two is four three and
one is for it's
different ways you could get there but
if the issue isn't that big
what's you know what's it hurting and
you help somebody
i love that that was awesome
you know if you have a pair of shoes and
you break them in you already
did that couple i mean did this person
watch out all over again
i'll make this work that's all you just
got to be in him for
the longest exactly that's it we're all
in
thank you very much thank you so much
for coming on the show
okay thank you for having us our next
question
is from denise who is single and
ready to settle down denise what is your
question for richard and rhoda
so i just moved here from australia this
year
kind of right as the pandemic escalated
so
it's been a super lonely time it's been
really hard
to meet people and make friends let
alone take control of my dating life
so i just kind of would love some advice
on um
how to go up to someone and actually
just ask them out how do i get the
courage to do that
a compliment breaks the ice for me
so i would think if you see somebody and
you're interested in them
you say excuse me i'm new here my name
is
but if they're married it's off limit
and you should know that
then you move on but it's easy to be
nice
and a compliment is the nicest way to
break the ice to me
you just want to get to know him yeah i
love that
you'll be surprised how many people are
waiting for someone to
make the first step i love them so much
it hurts
you